je crois que nous avons je marque je
crois que monsieur pierre debray qui est
le mari de madame sabran on est quand
même de surgir pour donner son avis il a
semblé de port de grâce est en train de
nous traiter de véhicules commandés
moche ça c'est moi j'ai pas oui vous
quand vous vous voterez comme ça veut
dire du cochon à vas-y chose et là je
défends cohn bendit cavache c'est je
crois une soirée suffisamment sérieuse
si vous pensez que ma place n'est pas
souhaitable puisque la droite elle a
gagné moi je laisse sa place à la droite
je vais ailleurs il entend alors rien
dire avant la 5e édition je parte à
pompe
monsieur mitterrand parce que moi
j'avais plein de notes en venant dans
l'autre dimension non je n'aurai pas le
temps je le sais déjà que j'ai pas le
temps c'est juste le temps de mettre en
colère je voulais convention d'accord
non c'est le système de la formation
française qui fait comme ça j'aurai le
temps une minute de m'énerver juste de
m'énerver de paraître pour un petit
merdeux un petit jeune de la pagaille
par cliff fletcher temps là le but pour
accepter mais il ya trois mois je vais
pas sûr qu'ils n'ont rien dit pour
l'instant c'est extrêmement désagréable
de discuter avec vous je crois que les
syndicats ont raison de protester contre
le fait que l'information avec vous sur
antenne 2 a du mal à s'exprimer
georges marchais on s'en fout de georges
marchais il faut le savoir ça de ce qui
faisait pendant la guerre ça nous c'est
complètement égal j'ai peut-être du
culot de faire ça je suis obligé de le
faire comme ça parce que je dois faire
vite
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que la
jeunesse se désespère les jeunes vont
finir par virer du mauvais côté parce
qu'ils n'auront plus d'autre solution
voilà je vous remercie d'avoir laissé
parler